In this section of our course, I will share some final recommendations, providing tips
and resources for you to use as you continue your training with MetaHumans.
We will look at ways we can approach making adjustments to MetaHuman components and how
we can make adjustments to our project render settings and environment when working with
MetaHumans in a level.
As we have seen throughout this course, we can make a variety of customizations to MetaHuman
components, their properties and assets.
Let's jump into Unreal Engine and take a look at a few simple adjustments we can make when
working with MetaHumans in a project.
Inside of Unreal Engine, let's begin making adjustments to MetaHuman components by first
going to our course topics folder and open the folder named Final Output.
Here we will find a cinematic sequence that contains various cameras along with a body
and facial animation.
I am going to double click on this to open it and now I will play the sequence.
To view this from the different cameras, click here on the Camera Cuts track.
Now I want to pause the sequence right here.
If for example we would like to make adjustments to the roughness of the skin, we can do this
inside of the skin material instance.
Let's select our MetaHuman in the viewport.
Then in the Details panel, select the face component and then go here and double click
on this.
To open up the material instance, I will double click on this.
Inside of here we have several parameters we can adjust.
For example, the artist delights allow us to control the makeup properties.
To adjust the roughness, I will scroll all the way down here and open up the roughness
parameters.
We can adjust the minimum and maximum roughness values and this will affect the roughness
on the entire face.
Another thing we can do is uncheck Baked Roughness Modulation over here.
This will unlock all of these parameters allowing us to control the roughness in specific areas
of the face.
If for instance we would like to reduce the roughness in the cheeks, we can lower the
value of the cheek front multiplier to something like .8.
We can do the same to the nose.
Here we can change the nose multiplier to something like .7.
The face material instance gives us control over even the finest detail.
Now let's close these and continue playing the sequence.
When we get to the section of the sequence where we can see the teeth, I will press pause.
Here we may want to adjust the way the teeth and light are interacting and we can do this
with the subsurface profile of the teeth.
I'm going to select the MetaHuman Blueprint in the viewport.
And in the details panel, select the face component.
Over here we can open up the teeth material instance.
The teeth material instance allows us to control things such as the base color of the teeth
and gums and we can also fine tune things such as the teeth and gum roughness.
Another thing we can do is go down here to the material property overrides and adjust
the subsurface profile.
By default this will be disabled but I have already enabled this by checking this on.
If we open this up, inside of here we can control the way light scatters as it passes
through semi-translucent surfaces such as the teeth and gums.
For example, the Mean Free Path Color controls how far light goes into the subsurface of
the red, green and blue channel.
If we change the red to something like 0.19 we can see that the teeth and gums become
more translucent.
The Mean Free Path Distance controls the distance that the Mean Free Path Color goes
into subsurface.
So for instance if we change the value to something like 0.19 we can see that the teeth
and gums become even more translucent.
Let's close these and continue.
I will continue playing the sequence.
When we get to this section here perhaps we want to change the color of the hair.
To do this I will select the metahuman, then go to the Details panel and select the Hair
component.
I will go here and open up the Hair Material instance.
Here we have a variety of parameters we can adjust.
For example we can adjust the Hair Melanin parameter.
If I change this value to something like 0.5 we can see the hair color changes.
We can also adjust the roughness and control the way hair and light interact.
Depending on the hairstyle we can also control properties such as the highlights and ombre.
These are a few simple adjustments we can make just through the material instances of
the metahuman components.
Now before we move on let's review what we just covered.
Something to note is that many of the selections we have made in the metahuman creator to things
such as the color of the eyes, the hair and some of the skin details can also be modified
in engine with the component material instances.
We have control over even the finest details such as the roughness for specific areas of
the face by unchecking the baked roughness modulation setting.
We can also control how light scatters as it passes through translucent and semi-translucent
surfaces such as the teeth, skin and eyes with the subsurface profile located in the
material property overrides of these material instances.
We can use the hair material instance to fine tune the appearance of the hair and adjust
things such as color, ombre and highlights.
We can also control the way hair reflections and lighting interact by adjusting the roughness
parameters.
Now there may be cases where we want to make adjustments to a metahuman blueprint while
preserving the original version.
An easy way we can approach this is to make adjustments to a child blueprint of a metahuman.
Let's jump back into Unreal Engine and go over this.
Inside of Unreal Engine with the folder of the metahuman we wish to adjust already opened,
select the blueprint and then right click on it.
Then select create child blueprint class.
Now we can make adjustments to this child metahuman blueprint and those changes will not affect
the original one.
You can open up this child blueprint and make changes such as switch the groom component
asset with a different hairstyle, assign a different animation blueprint to the face
or body or even do something as simple as forcing the LOD to something like 3.
Now if we go back to our main viewport and drop this into a level we can see the changes
we made are only applied to the child blueprint of this metahuman.
For certain shared assets such as materials those assets will have to be duplicated and
a copy can be assigned and then adjusted otherwise those types of adjustments will affect the
original blueprint.
Let's review what we've just covered before we move on.
We have just touched upon how we can approach making changes to a copy of an existing metahuman
blueprint without those changes affecting the original by using a child blueprint.
To create a child blueprint simply right click on the metahuman blueprint and select create
child blueprint class.
From there you can change things such as forcing the LOD to something specific, switching out
the hair grooms or assigning a different animation blueprint to one of the skeletal mesh components
with the exception of shared assets such as materials.
Now let's move on to the next section of this course.